even vardinger Brook lives in the
Netherlands which has long been Europe's
biggest food producer now it's the
global center of the bug food industry
she joins us tonight for an update on
what it's like to subsist on crickets
Eva thanks so much for joining us so
your country the Netherlands is famous
for its agricultural output now it's
famous for insects this feels like the
Leading Edge of a global Trend do you
think that it is
absolutely there's no surprise there I
mean my country really is sadly the
pilot country for an organization like
the world economic Forum we are sort of
the tester kit of the 2030 agenda so the
fact that we the second largest exporter
of agricultural products in the world
our nation with such a rich farming
history is now cracking down on its
farms and opening insect factories
should be of no surprise to you and you
know this is not something that is just
going to affect the food supply of the
Netherlands like I said we're the second
largest exporter of agricultural
products in the world after America so
this will influence the food supply
worldwide and we've spoken to Farmers
who said well this could lead to actual
starvation if we're not careful
I I have to ask about the role of the
population in this since purportedly the
Netherlands like the United States is a
democracy do the people of the
Netherlands want to eat bugs is this
happening because there was a popular
outcry bring us more bugs
no of course not nobody's being asked
and I think that that's the point you
know nobody really inherently wants to
eat bugs when we think about bugs we you
know curly things you know nobody wants
to eat that but they're telling us that
it's good for the climate that this is
the way that we can save the planet and
that that little stake that you have on
your plate that gives you some joy in
life is that what actually ruins the
world and of course none of that is true
I think that the push for insect eating
is just a compliance test because our
politicians know that when they control
the food they control the people
I mean why not earthworms and rats as
long as you're humiliating people on
purpose by making the meat repulsive
things
exactly well I think that that's the
whole point so you know don't give them
any ideas Ducker I think the the rats
and then the mice and all of that are
next on the menu after the Crickets that
they now are trying to put in our food
so my last question is what what is the
pushback been like a country with a
thousand year history of growing food
has got to be resistant to this have
people made that clear that resistance
yeah absolutely we've had massive
protests so our Farmers protest that you
and I have been speaking about plenty of
times now and that also have been
featured in this documentary they've
been very successful so we actually had
elections just now in the Netherlands
where a lot of people actually the
largest party was the farmer's party so
the Dutch people don't want to be eating
insects we understand that a traditional
profession such as farming that we have
been good at for centuries on end is not
the cause of a modern day so-called
crisis such as climate change so no the
people know what they want we don't want
to be eating insects we want our steak
and as long as we well keep saying no to
this in this insect Bush we might still
have a chance of eating it but I really
do feel like now is the time to say no
exactly farmers are not the problem
overpaid non-profit Executives and
politicians are the problem obviously
Eva Florida thank you very much for
joining us as always
thank you Tucker
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight